ukraine and the special media operation
that has russian journalists under
control
downing street 1 fleet street nil
the times of london crumbles under
political pressure
plus
the julian assange case
and how authoritarian regimes are using
it to their advantage
hello i'm richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we provide
explanatory journalism about journalism
and the global news media it's now been
four months more than 100 days since
russia invaded ukraine a war that looks
like it could last for years the
propaganda around this conflict is also
escalating shifting in both tone and
content
in russia independent journalism has all
but disappeared clearing the way for the
kremlin's narrative to go unopposed
state-controlled television channels and
newspapers serve as the putin
government's messengers they've got the
country on a war footing while
maintaining the rhetorical illusion that
russian forces aren't even in a war just
a special military operation and they
are mocking the parade of western
leaders making visits to the ukrainian
capital our starting point this week is
kiev
[Music]
they keep rolling into kiev
world leaders
hollywood celebrities lining up to meet
with president vladimir zelinsky
signaling their support providing
ammunition for the information war
the leaders of italy france germany and
romania visited the president of ukraine
and key thursday
but ukrainians are now more than 100
days into this and the photo ops cannot
obscure the fact that russia controls 20
of their country
not that the facts are of particular
interest to russian news channels that
have ridiculed zelensky all along and
have recently altered their messaging
refined it for audiences at home and
abroad
in the beginning of the war it was about
ukrainian politicians it was about
ukrainian president elensky lots of dogs
trying to to make him look stupid or
not really important and now it's about
world leaders it's about other countries
it's not only about ukraine
they're making fun of macron and
zelensky hugging
they are saying also that johnson has a
lot of problems
inside of his own country
and he uses ukraine for his own purposes
they're saying that there is no war in
ukraine
if the leaders of
big european countries are visiting
ukraine right now it means that there
has not been
any war there going on and this is the
proof for the audience of this
propaganda channels that
listen guys this is special military
operation it's concentrated
on the east of ukraine
and quite shockingly russia is setting
up
information
centers which are really large tv
screens on trucks that they roll up into
even places as devastated as mariupol
and uh
when you're in a queue in uh mario pal
waiting for food you will be shown such
programs being told that you've been
liberated against fascism as you look
around the devastated landscape of your
city
and then critically they're really
making the point that the economic
degradation of the global system caused
by the sanctions
is really biting
challenging the west to say okay you've
supported ukraine but the price of gas
is so high do you really want to keep
you know your your generosity towards
ukraine
what has not changed is russia's
insistence that this is not a war just a
special military operation
it is a term that grows more absurd with
every bomb that falls every life that is
lost
but russia's foreign minister was
sticking to that story in an interview
he recently gave the bbc
the kremlin seldom grants such
interviews this one was conducted in
russian and sergey lavrov seemed better
prepared for the bbc
than the bbc was for him
i cannot say that ralof fully succeeded
with that but he was pretty close to
guiding the interview because lavrov was
not made to answer actually any question
from the anchor
and that's why i think this interview
was a kind of failure because when the
anchor tries to stick to neutral
standards he is predicting that his
respondent will answer these questions
and will play within the same rules of
the game but lavrov was playing his own
game
the lava of interview was a masterful
political piece he knows how to work the
interview he doesn't accept any of the
counter questions he denies all the
facts
he talks over any questions he doesn't
agree with he challenges the journalists
back and notably it was conducted in
russian and we could assume it was
required to be conducted in russia so it
must be that it was intended to be aired
in the russian uh uh audience
and of course you're asking why would he
speak with uh bbc at all
i would tell you this is for russian
propaganda the channels telegram
channels and
and other um media organizations
connected with kremlin
to quote lavrov and to show
russians
how strong and smart
and
authoritative he is
and they are they are now laughing at
bbc
and
adoring
sergei lavrov one of the main faces of
this of this terrible war
going back to the special military
operation the orwellian absurdity of
that term
more and more cracks are starting to
show on the russian airwaves
it remains technically illegal to call
it a war yet news anchors are allowed to
frame ukraine as part of a larger war on
nato or war on the west
and despite the orders from on high and
all those obedient russian journalists
sometimes the truth just slips out
fleeting moments of accuracy in the
kremlin-controlled news media accidental
ones
it's interesting that it it seeps
through from time to time talk shows
refer to war correspondence being on the
scene which was an interesting uh usage
even the russian ambassador we have a
prolongation of war they have may have
slipped to use that term so it slips out
but if you were an activist or if you
used it purposefully you would uh
potentially suffer consequences
it's done with kind of
wing
like everybody understand in russia that
it's it is a war so we are trying to
save them the outsiders with all these
wars
and it gives
ordinary people
feel that they belong to something
bigger
we are trying to
play with the west trying to deceive
them
and we are ordinary russians we are part
of this game that makes us bigger
in russia where freedom of expression is
under siege and people have good reason
to fear speaking freely to journalists
and even pollsters it is impossible to
accurately measure public opinion
but even russian opponents of the war in
ukraine concede that most of their
fellow citizens support it
as for the more complicated questions of
why and how much the russian media have
to do with that
those are things we may never really
know
listen
people want to believe that this is a
special military operation people want
to trust their government because if
they don't then they need to acknowledge
that their country is killing civilians
right now
that's why millions of russians do not
want to
to understand the reality
and it's more comfortable for them
to believe this propaganda to trust
these liars
and to feel themselves as just viewers
not participants
are russian people supporting the war
because of the media or are they
happily consuming the official line
because they wish to receive it
ukrainian friends even they have said
that the russian
state media is so
harsh and ferocious that even they get
dizzy over time when they listen to it
and lose their bearings
i think there is still a light hope that
the white russian public will start
doubting what is being delivered to them
through official
sources of information
the number of russian soldiers coming
back home that will be critical or when
ordinary russians will start feeling
after effects of sanctions
they might start thinking at some point
that the real picture of the war in
ukraine is different
from what has being broadcasted on state
tv channels
now you see it now you don't an
explosive news report is rippling across
the world of british politics it's the
story of an illicit affair corruption
scheming and state censorship meenakshi
ravi is here with more
an article published by the times of
london on june 18th revealed that
british prime minister boris johnson had
tried to hire his now wife as his chief
of staff back in 2018 when he was
foreign secretary and was having an
extra-marital affair with her the job
comes with a hefty salary and it was
only the strong disapproval of johnson's
advisors that scuppered his plans
that article managed to make it to some
print copies of the times but then
disappeared from later editions and
never made it to the paper's website
10 downing street has since admitted
that it demanded the times pull the
story even though there was no denial of
the allegation and elements of the story
had been published elsewhere before
the times has offered no explanation for
why it caved to the demands of the prime
minister's office and the paper's
readers are not letting this go
the comment sections across numerous
other political articles have been
jammed
boris johnson has been lurching from
scandal to scandal and british media
outlets have broken numerous stories of
prime ministerial parties during covet
lockdowns corruption infighting and the
erosion of government services johnson
has survived and the pushback from
downing street against journalists has
been aggressive
from not providing government
representatives for media questioning to
ongoing pressure on news outlets like
the bbc and channel 4 to incidents like
this the johnson government keeps going
after the messengers
thanks mina it took a while but the
metoo movement has finally come to the
forefront in greece
the threats faced by greek women from
sexual harassment to domestic violence
are making headlines including the
ultimate form of gender violence
femicide the intentional killing of
women simply because they are women
38 have been killed over the past 18
months most often at the hands of
current or ex-partners
greece is one of europe's most
patriarchal societies ranking dead last
in the eu's gender equality index and
that is reflected in the country's news
media
the listening posts flow phillips now on
femicide in greece and the sometimes
detrimental role that journalism has
played there in the way such crimes have
been reported
first came the pictures a family in
mourning
then came the words spoken by the
widowed husband
a funeral tribute from a young father to
his murdered wife as he held their baby
[Music]
the baby's mother was a woman named
caroline crouch and as the story went
she was beaten and strangled to death in
her athens home by a gang of ruthless
foreign robbers
it was a crime story made for television
with elements of glamour and gore almost
too scripted to be believed
and the greek media feasted on it
it satisfied all of greek society's
stereotypes
a beautiful family the breadwinner
bobbis a handsome successful pilot and
his wife caroline
they lived in a beautiful masonette
where they were bringing up their
beautiful baby daughter that would be
enough to fulfill all societal norms of
what a family should look like but then
this perfect family is under attack by
who by armed foreign burglars
the greek media turned that material
into juicy content and the viewers into
collective mourners
it took 37 days for the real story to
come out
the revelation that crouch was in fact
murdered by her own husband left greeks
reeling
and yet the mainstream media
they weren't ready to let go of their
narrative
the coverage of the facts was
problematic
there was a reporter on sky tv who after
babies had confessed to the murder still
referred to him as the alleged suspect
she stated that at least he didn't cut
her up
it was almost like he was giving the
suspect an alibi
instead of calling him out for this
heinous crime
that happened because babis was the
son-in-law that everyone in greek
society wanted to have it's just that he
turned out to be a murderer the more
conservative wing of the greek media
were eager to justify his actions
[Music]
suddenly caroline was depicted as a
foreign woman way too dynamic and vocal
[Laughter]
and according to a tv psychologist
babies was the one who had the ideal
online profile that would get him many
followers
gender determines how the media research
and report on a story and it ends up
being entirely confusing
it feels like mainstream media here
often focused more on the woman for
getting the actual criminal
the victim was pretty she was a kind
person a young mother
greek television usually chooses to
stick to journalistic cliches
and by choosing not to refer to these
killings as femicides we end up with
coverage that murders the victim for a
second time
the impact of femicide goes beyond the
loss of life
these are crimes that tap into a
collective fear
so how the media treat them really
matters
unfortunately for many years now the
greek media haven't helped to bring
about a zero tolerance culture for
gender violence
just the opposite
like sound bites that are sympathetic to
the murderer coming from the police
department
stavros velazquez was a senior officer
on the caroline crouch case
that sound bite came to be known as the
velazquez doctrine advice delivered on
camera on how to escape true justice a
life sentence if you murder your wife
just call the police and confess right
away
there was no follow-up from the
journalist no pushback
was it any coincidence then that in the
weeks after more men came forward
confessing to killing their partners
here is yet another example of us
journalists being caught by surprise
we weren't aware of the incredible
social impact the statement would have
and we should have emphasized how
important it was to address it
the journalist never questioned the
statement or even triggered a dialogue
around it
the murder of caroline crouch should not
be seen in isolation
feminist groups estimate that over the
past 10 years gender-based violence has
trickled in greece
and currently at least one woman dies at
the hands of a man every month
like garafalia zaraco pushed off the
volegandros cliffs by her boyfriend
nektaria meraki stabbed 16 times by her
estranged husband
odora zaharia gunned down by her former
partner on the island of rothos
but tune in to any of greece's many
popular tv shows and you'd be left
guessing as to who the real victims are
in the case of thora the suspect's uncle
got a lot of air time to enhance the
killer's profile
the truth is the greek media reflect the
gender inequality that exists in society
at large and they always emphasize the
fact that the suspect has never been in
trouble with the authorities
the uncle was publicly expressing the
other side of the story he came on my
show and blamed the woman saying that
her morals were questionable
you know it's a relief for those of us
who present souls like mine to be able
to show viewers both sides of the
argument no matter how difficult it is
for us as journalists
because a coin always has two sides the
accused leaves his own truth
zena kucillini doesn't mince her words
she's a host for star channel and one of
the country's most famous faces for more
than three decades she's been part of
the greek media establishment in a
country where entrenched patriarchal
views have been slow to change
i believe that if all women unite and
support each other men will follow
to some extent
we are to blame for this current
situation
when i present femicide on my soul do
you know what i observe i observe that
if the blame is placed on the woman
women stop watching while men continue
women don't have the strength of
character to face their own truths
it's very important to be able to look
yourself in the eye and tell yourself
it's your fault that you are putting up
with your husband
please
let's not blame everything on the
patriarchy
when we talk about patriarchy sexism or
toxic masculinity in greece there's
always this strange reaction sometimes
it's laughter but some women get abused
for bringing these issues up and they're
never mentioned on greek television
i actually don't think i've heard the
word patriarchy used on greek tv in
years
as it happens the word patriarchy comes
from greek patriarchy
it means rule of the father and covering
women the violence they suffer remains a
challenge for greek news organizations
with their culture of male dominance
to this day
and finally julian assange is one step
closer to an american prison the uk
government has agreed to extradite the
wikileaks co-founder he faces a sentence
of up to 175 years
julian assange is guilty of exposing
american secrets including war crimes in
afghanistan and iraq through classified
documents that wikileaks published and
then provided to news outlets around the
world
assange's backers have always maintained
that this case is bigger than him in
that it sets a menacing precedent for
journalism that is in the public
interest
and the assange case gives repressive
regimes around the world a tailor-made
talking point to use against their
critics including the u.s
because if the americans jail assange
for his work why can't other political
actors do the same to their journalists
we're leaving you now with a few
examples of how those regimes play the
assange card whenever it suits them and
we'll see you next time here at the
listening post
is
[Music]
[Music]
in order to accuse me saying that
armenians will not have free media here
let's talk about assange how many years
sorry how many years he spent in
ecuadorian embassy and for what and
where is he now for journalistic
activity you kept that person hostage
actually killing him morally and
physically
you did it not us and now he's in prison
[Music]
foreign
that